so I take I take Nia
to go see the Milwaukee Bucks against
the Lakers right oh it's going yeah The
Greek Freak first LeBron but LeBron
broke Kareem's record the night before
so he went out boozing or whatever you
know he twisted his ankle he couldn't
play which I respected I respected that
right so
we got great seats my manager hooks us
up
we're down in like the [__] VIP thing
underneath the the bleachers or whatever
and was sitting there and in walks
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar and I'm like holy
[__] [__] because they can do like a
presentation thing
so I'm sitting there and Nia is just
Starstruck she's like oh my god I've
never seen her so Starstruck she's like
that's Korea told you about oh my God
so she goes
do you think I could go up and get a
picture with him I said no I go don't do
that don't do that he doesn't like that
stuff I'm telling you and like I'm a
huge fan of Kareem and like and I'm not
talking about
like basketball I mean the person
like his his this guy can talk about
anything you want he's a [__]
intellectual
trapped in a seven foot body
and all little white guys want to do is
come up and talk to him about putting a
[__] ball through a hoop so it's just
like no I'm no Lee I'm telling you it's
not going to be good you look at him
he's over there he's not looking at
anybody just don't leave this guy alone
right so she's like all right all right
yeah it's like I want to [__] with this
guy like
um he probably doesn't even want to be
here
right can't wait for this ceremony to be
officer and get the [__] out of here and
go read some book on uh you know
astrophysics or something right so
I'm [__] sitting there and then as he
goes to get out and he is like oh there
he is there he is and some like you know
sort of like botox mom's like I got
crazy and she does a selfie with them
and he kind of did it
so she's got going bill bill so I go all
right maybe and I went up ah
no I went up to him no
and this is my end was
he wrote an article and when he he said
some comedians names he mentioned my
name
so I went up to him and I said hey cream
uh sorry to bother you I'm Bill Burr I'm
a comedian you mentioned me one time in
one of your articles and he's like way
up here not looking at me and he just
goes I did and I was like oh no oh
oh
I don't remember the rest of the
conversation I think my voice went up
and Trail I was like yeah maybe you
think
did you do a picture or no he just
walked away oh my god oh dude I was
hoping the end dude that stayed with me
until mid-second quarter and Nia was
going like I thought you were going to
be having a better time at the game and
I was like
dude I can't believe I I knew that was
gonna happen I knew that was gonna
happen and then another thing too is I
love that that doesn't change I still
love that guy I hate that I bonded him
oh I hate that I became just another guy
that [__] bothered him I did oh my
God he just threw me on the pilot jerk
offs that he has to Wade through
when I look at those guys I'm like that
has got to be the [__] it's it's like
a prison
yeah he can't put a hat on when you're
seven [__] tall even if you're not
famous
uh you're seven feet tall and you work
at a [__] Home Depot people are
looking at you okay you don't need a
forklift do you there buddy right your
whole [__] leg
right nobody [__] sees you and that
like um I read his articles and [__] and
I really like I don't agree with
everything that he says but like
like he really has
um
he's so beyond the game of basketball
and I was just like I am not gonna
dude that's incredible story that is
[__] nuts dude oh dude I feel like
I'm embarrassed again as I tell it but I
I still 100 love the guy
and uh if I could do it over again I
wouldn't have bothered him
right I know somebody's saying that
about Tom Brady you ever meet Tom Brady
like I know I haven't you go dude you
would absolutely freak out if you met
him I said I would you know my gift for
him would be for six Super Bowls in 20
years of winning I wouldn't I would
leave him alone
yeah it would be one less jerk off
coming up here hey take you the greatest
and just [__] let him
spinach is scallops
I pride myself on doing that and you
know what I [__]
dude that story hurt me that story hurt
me because I know how much it hurt you
this is why you know what my wife loves
me so much it hurt her because she was
just like
um I I didn't know I thought because I
was like I know I know that woman took
the picture
she just kind of went up a dish like I
got cream
oh man yeah he had no choice uh Paul I
don't know if I can I don't know if I
can finish this podcast I'm so [__]
embarrassed and then right as I was
starting to forget
[Music]
right as I was starting to forget
sometime in the second half they came
out with him in the crowd waving
uncomfortably